citizens of the reject nation as you may
have heard of late things are a little
bit uh rocky over at warner brothers dc
we've got a lot of announcements we've
heard a lot of cancellations we've heard
a lot about reboots we've got movies
still coming out we've got movies in
post-production there's a lot going on
but i think there is a solution that
they might do that would solve the
reboot problem the matt reeves batman
problem and make the current fans of the
dc eu happy and it's all comic book
canon this is that journey i'm gonna
explain it all but first please leave a
like leave a comment let me know what
you think about this grand reboot idea
that'll be very interesting for all
parties involved please do hit that
subscription bell it'll notify you of
other videos just like this one also
please follow me on tik tok where i give
all sorts of 15 second 30 second one
minute three minute short form versions
of videos just like this full of comic
nerd savvy and to talk about movies and
stuff let's dive into how to reboot the
dceu
[Music]
so with batgirl cancelled and black adam
flash shazam aquaman joker 2 peacemaker
season 2 and another few things up in
the air we've heard david zasloff does
want an mcu-esque 10-year plan going
forward looking to reboot the dc
universe but with certain things in
production certain other things in
post-production certain things with
release dates what does that look like
how do you reboot while also making the
og fans happy and how do you do that
with the matt reeves batman carrying on
which it does seem to be now there is a
comic solution to this and i think would
be the strength of both dc
and marvel i think this would utilize
everything marvel is doing well but also
be the strength that dc has had the last
few years now personally one of the
things i've really enjoyed about dc is
that they've let the movies live and
breathe on their own i like personally
that the shazam movie felt like an old
amblin film mixed with comic book
elements and the batman movie felt like
a david fincher film those movies would
never work in the same universe i also
enjoyed the fact that i could watch
peacemaker that could be rated r and
that felt completely separate of
everything except the suicide squad i do
honestly think batman and joker in those
separate movies never meeting was a
strength of dc because that's a lot like
the comic books there are different
continuity but when you've got marvel
when you've got the strength of marvel
you make it that you can't miss a film
right it's an installment it's almost a
long form tv series if you miss an
episode you'll get what's going on but
it won't be as fulfilling so marvel has
made a lot of must-watch television
through disney plus as well as
must-watch movies where you care about
every single character on the roster at
least enough to go see it in theater i
understand why the dc universe wants to
mirror the strengths of marvel marvel
looked at the greater mcu and went hey
this is only so sustainable if we don't
let the directors make their vision if
everything feels similar to each other
that can be a pro anacon and multiverse
madness let sam raimi for the most part
make a giant sam raimi film but marvel
fans got a little fan entitlement and
wanted more more of what the trailer
showed which was a lot of the multiverse
stuff we'd already seen now that's a
tricky line to walk because marvel's
trying to give the fans they want they
listen to the fans they read the message
boards they're very engaged but
inherently you can't give everyone
everything they want if you're living in
this one big sandbox you can't let sam
raimi make a full-on sam raimi film and
also have it be the multiverse madness
that a lot of fans expect and i think
that was also somewhat of an issue with
the taiko a td film having it be so
versed in comedy and drama but also
being a thor film that has to carry on
the mcu so what i would do is i would
make one more dceu film i would have
black adam and shazam duke it out and
maybe have a shazam 3 or a black atom
two were that got brought together i
would leave that over here i know
they've got scenes of the snyder films
in that movie but that personally would
be its own thing i would have aquaman
and the flash come out if they want the
flash to come out have that be the last
thing leading especially since that's a
flashpoint movie to a crisis on infinite
earths now in the comic books this is
how you reset continuity dc has done it
a number of times after a long enough
run of comic books people get sick of a
certain idea people get sick of a
character acting a certain way people
get sick of this longer run on
continuity it's very intimidating
sometimes to buy an issue 612 sometimes
you want to go buy an issue number one
if a comic's been running for a certain
amount of time the number feels
intimidating to dive into and the
characterization feels intimidating to
try to invest it so you reboot and the
way dc does that is through this crisis
concept do that with the movies make one
more movie and make it be the secret
wars that i think we're leading to in
marvel but for dc and they've already
done this on tv there was a crisis event
on tv that was very successful and if
you do this for the movies bring henry
cavill back have that one more
appearance of superman have your
multiple batmans with michael keaton and
ben affleck have all the things we've
wanted to see these characters get to do
much like the snyder cut have that big
epic and
bring in the tv show characters i almost
guarantee stephen amell would come back
to play arrow if it's in a movie that
brings all this together i almost
guarantee that after season nine of
flash which feels kind of convenient
grant gustin could play this character
one more time we'd get this big moment
have an epic event the likes of which
we're getting in a few years of secret
wars spend the money spend the
i know it's going to be insane like 250
million dollars but the way you wrap
that movie is you have the biggest hall
h or fandom announcement of all time by
having that continuity wiped out and
have a new 52-esque team introduced at
the end of that movie have your cast
of the new universe revealed in a giant
new justice league that way the way dc
wants to run into things is by having
you know their justice league movie from
the jump we saw with the last iteration
they did man of steel right into batman
v superman right into justice league
have the justice league fully formed we
all know batman's origin i don't need to
see another set of pearls break we all
know who superman is but we don't want
to see the same iteration if they want
to reboot give them a comic canon reboot
that takes place right at the very end
and there's your new characters and then
what you do is you have a universe
that's the justice league shared
universe dceu in the truest sense have a
dc extended universe that a lot of
people have wanted that it sounds like
david saslov wants a shared universe a
lot of the mcu but what you can do with
a crisis on infinite earths is you also
keep over here a disjointed dc black
label universe in the comic books
there's an entirely different imprint
and the books are as actually physically
different they don't look like regular
comic books some of them do most of them
are more of an album shape they're
squared off they feel like more of a
book and it's a comic book that's
r-rated is a black label book that's a
completely different continuity it's all
the same characters but it's not the
same continuity and they typically are
darker here is where you have matt
reeves batman where you have todd
phillips joker where you continue the
shazam and black adam storyline where
you keep going with lastic man's story
that we've been teased for years have
the directors get to make their vision
with their individual characters and
literally just call it something else
call it the black label films call it dc
something else and you have
what dc's been doing incredibly which is
letting directors share their vision
over here and then you've got the shared
universe of dc characters in this
justice league film and you reboot
however you choose now what i'm hoping
they do is they have green lantern exist
over here as the space cop is meant to
be that character should never interact
with robert pattinson's batman nor
should he necessarily interact with
black adam you also have a new batman
and superman that don't have the history
of them having fought yes batman and
superman fought in the comic it didn't
make sense then in that medium and that
medium is a lot more forgiving it's a
guy fighting an all-powerful alien it's
a rich dude i know there's that cannon
of if batman had long enough to plan he
could beat anybody it doesn't make sense
that bruce wayne could even fight to a
sand still with clark kent it doesn't
make sense what you do what i would do
is have the already established world of
gods that the dc represent and you have
batman as our eye line he's the guy
that's looking around at this world that
he's trying to navigate he's the world's
greatest detective he's the smartest guy
have your new batman trying to navigate
this world of dc it's not gonna be fun
to lose this incredible team of of
actors and filmmakers like jason momoa
and gal gadot and all these people but
if you're gonna reboot do it from a
place where everyone's on the same page
and then do what marvel has been doing
in their phase three four and going
forward have a movie come out a quarter
have this all scheduled out have a 10
year plan that literally introduces
these characters in a crisis event and
then one movie come out after another
hit that winter movie hit the spring hit
the summer hit the fall and then grow at
universe quickly but have these
characters already established because
we don't need another origin but again
shared universe here dc black label here
have your cake and eat it too let one
universe be shared let one universe be
this director's vision and that way you
literally thrive in both realities i
think a crisis movie could give us all
this i think i want to see more of
peacemaker i think i want to see more of
matt reeves batman i think i want to see
two separate universes and this is
something they can do if they just make
one more movie and that movie is already
comic can so i think in your one shared
universe you lean into the easter eggs
you lean into this shared world you lean
into all the things does make the mcu
thrive and in the other universe you
have that guillermo del toro justice
league dark movie we never got we get
all these other opportunities and i
think that's what we need to look at
these movies as is this is an adaptation
of a comic book it's not a translation
of a comic book the comic book medium
allows for more suspension of disbelief
because you're the one painting the
moving pictures when you look at a comic
book the space between the panels is
your imagination your creativity when
you look at a movie that's someone
showing you their vision of the story
that someone painting the picture for
you they're giving you this delivery you
need to understand that when you're
making a shared universe and i think
that's the benefit of starting over is
knowing that going forward allows you to
make things so it's not as unbelievable
as batman and superman fighting so it's
not as disparate as someone that's a
street level somehow just now
encountering green lantern make a
universe where the suspension of
disbelief is equal across all the
justice league characters and then make
another universe where zatanna makes as
much sense as plastic man as much sense
as matt reeves batman and all those
things have one disconnected
intentionally have one connected
intentionally have your cake eat it too
have a good time gonna give you some
comic recommendations now i'm only going
to give you three but this is for the
main three this is the trinity of dc
you're batman you're superman or wonder
woman i think the tone they should try
to land with is with batman go with the
new 52 batman go with scott snyder's
batman lean into the court of owl's
flavor he'll do the court of owls story
i think they'd be a great first movie
for this batman i know they might be
doing quarterbacks matt reeves batman
but i want to establish gotham as
somewhere near metropolis but not in
metropolis i want them to establish
batman as a guy that's aware of the
greater world around them that can also
have his own independent movies he needs
to know clark kent's out there but it
doesn't need to be his every waking
moment for wonder woman i would do the
george perez omnibus this is a story of
gods this is the story of powerful women
this is a story of bounty this book is
gorgeous and it's also who i see diana
prince as and i really think they need
to establish diana prince in this world
we need again her to be her own
character but also be able to team up
with these other very different worlds
and then lastly i really think that
superman needs to be superman he needs
to be the boy scout he is he needs to be
someone that knows his biggest flaw is
that he can't save everyone superman is
the most powerful creature on earth but
it's physically impossible even with
super speed and super hearing to hear
everyone's cry for help and stop and
save everything i think superman red and
blue jeff loeb tim sale captures
superman's weakness isn't just
kryptonite it's the fact that he can't
be everywhere and that's really
important i want a superman that feels
like someone you can meet and look up to
but his inherent flaws that he just
can't do it all i want superman's burden
to be that give me those those are your
comic recommendations check them out
what do you guys think about my reboot
into universe idea what do you think
about keeping one universe darker and
separate versus keeping one all tied
together what do you guys think about
the reboot in general and do you want a
crisis on infinite earth's bringing the
tv shows the movies together bringing
these actors back having one big blowout
and ending them i want henry cavill back
at least once give him give me give me
superman back all right you lovelies
that's gonna do it for this episode i
appreciate the hell out of each and
every one of you leading to new gods mr
miracle movie dark universe give me that
all right read some comics i'll see you
soon
[Music]